why
hello there you radical freedom
extremists
i'm your host dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message
it is december 11 20
20 friday december 11th it's almost the
weekend it's hard to tell
whether it's a weekend or a weekday
these days but it is almost the weekend
i don't want to get myself in any
trouble but i might have visitors coming
this weekend they
might even be in my house right now
don't tell on me
um all right we're doing an uh ask me
anything today
uh we've had about 100 questions
submitted
at reubenreport.com over on our uh
locals
community which if you aren't a member i
would welcome you to
to join us there are no trolls there are
no bots
we've put the social back in social
media there are real people
actually communicating with me and each
other and we're going to be doing this
ask me anything for about a half hour so
if you want to try to get a question in
uh you can jump on and maybe i'll do it
right now
reubenreport.com uh one other thing you
know i've been talking about doing a
movie night for a while we did a whole
bunch of them with the community
at the beginning of lockdown you
remember like 87 lives ago at the
beginning of lockdown when it was
a little sort of exciting you know what
i mean there was like this feeling for
like two or three weeks during lockdown
like oh we're all kind of going through
this thing together
oh we're on zoom calls we're doing
family group face times
this is kind of fun and weird and
everything will get back to normal even
though from the beginning i kept saying
nothing's ever getting back to normal
uh well we did a couple uh movie events
with the reuben report community we
watched the movie
contact we watched idiocracy we did a
couple others and then i do a big zoom
chat with people and we share thoughts
and everything else well we are bringing
it back
on tuesday and i think we're going to do
what
is probably the most apropos movie there
is besides contagion because that was
about a real uh pandemic um we are gonna
do
v for vendetta which i hope that most of
you have seen already but i think it's
sort of the perfect
movie for the moment uh because
it's about government overreach more
than anything else and while yes we do
have a pandemic before
you media matters losers clip that that
i think that i just said a second ago
yes there is a pandemic
but i'm far more worried about the
overreach of government and shutdowns
and as
v says in the movie uh government should
fear their people
people should not fear their government
so we're going to do that on tuesday
at 5 00 pm pacific then we do a giant
zoom after could be hundreds of people
in there
and maybe we'll do a little live
chatting throughout the movie we do it
on netflix watch and
you can find out more about that in the
reuben report community
and i'm going to get to as many
questions as possible i am going to do
just one story before we do
that because you know this whole hunter
biden thing
that everyone is suddenly talking about
has really taken on
a life into its own because it sort of
gets to what i'm always talking about
about this reality war
that if you pay attention to things
online if you if you select some
interesting
people on youtube or via podcast or
whatever else
to talk about to listen to things about
and communicate about
then you would know that there's been
something going on with hunter biden's
laptop for quite some time the story
that broke from the new york post that
twitter censored
that the mainstream media basically
ignored before the election
and suddenly it's reaching critical mass
now that they believe joe biden has won
and suddenly there's a feeling of oh we
can't ignore this anymore and it's
bursting into mainstream so i wanted to
point out a couple things here just
specifically about the story because it
is something that you should actually
know about
and then we'll do a little bit of sort
of the way the media is doing their
their usual cover-up job so
the blaze has obviously been reporting
on this and they said that hunter biden
the son of former
vice president joe biden said that he
was under investigation by the u.s
attorney general's office in delaware
maryland okay so that's hunter biden
himself saying
he is under investigation now this is
exactly what people were talking about
for about a month
before the election but who was talking
about it was only
the right wing maniacs those fox news
people and those
newsmax people and those crazy
conspiracy theorists and nazis and the
rest of it
it wasn't the respectable journalists of
cnn and npr in new york times no no no
they didn't want to touch it
we're going to show you right now so
this is these are two politico
headlines just to show you the stupidity
of the way they manipulate you
uh the one on the left the headline on
the left is uh from before the election
and the headline on the right is just
from the last day or two so on the left
hunter biden's story is russian dis info
dozens of former intel officials say now
of course they're always anonymous
intel officials like the anonymous
sources on capitol hill or
whenever stelter or acosta or one of
these losers at cnn
they always have these anonymous sources
and it's just made-up people it's
literally their imaginary friends
so before the election again hunter
biden's story is russian disinfo have we
heard that before
dozens of former intel officials say uh
now
post-election this is just from the last
day or two justice department's interest
in hunter biden covered more than
taxes oh so suddenly i guess it's not
russian disinfo it's something that the
justice department's
actually looking into and it has not
only to do with his taxes but perhaps
something much more well that's sort of
interesting
i thought this one was worth showing you
guys as well because again i'm just
trying to paint a picture of what
happens where we forget week to week
how these media organizations manipulate
us so this is from
terran samuel of npr now npr is still
somehow funded by the government your
tax dollars
go to fund npr which is absolutely
insane there is media
all over the place and for some reason
the government funds
nonsensical leftist drivel well here's
what npr
said about the hunter biden story which
again was in the new york post a
respectable newspaper it's a tabloid for
sure i grew up in
in new york city uh most of my adult
life was in new york city reading the
new york post it is what it is
uh but nobody was challenging the
veracity of clay of the claims in the
story
npr said before the election we don't
want to waste
our time on stories that are not really
stories and we don't want to waste the
listeners and readers time on stories
that are just pure distractions
and quite frankly that's where we ended
up this was a politically driven event
and we decided to treat it that way so
in essence
before the election they decided oh this
doesn't
really fit the narrative because this is
going to make joe biden look bad
right because his son is deeply corrupt
and got that job in the ukraine
and everything else on top of whatever
else is on the laptop and the drug use
and all of that stuff
and this ain't gonna look good for biden
so we can't talk about it before the
election
uh this is a quote from david shalane of
cnn this is before the election he said
obviously
we're not going with the new york post
story right now on hunter biden
and the reason i thought that quote was
worth it because it's just like oh we
just dismiss it
obviously we dismiss it it's just crazy
right wing lunacy
and then nbc news uh pre-election a fake
persona laid the groundwork for a hunter
biden
conspiracy deluge i could have picked a
gajillion more stories or blue check
people on twitter to show you
how they were dismissing it and now it's
sort of coming around
and they're finally begrudgingly having
to talk about it but i thought that was
just a good way to kick us off today and
now i'm going to try we got
i think literally over 100 questions i'm
going to try to get to as many as
possible
as quickly as possible they're all over
the map some are political some are
personal some are
about tvs music books everything else
okay landon
asks since you met sydney powell is she
crazy or does she actually have
something
okay so if you didn't hear i was at the
white house hanukkah party on
uh wednesday and i stayed at the trump
hotel and as i was waiting
uh to head over to the white house and i
was actually at a at a meeting before
then which
maybe i'll tell you about at another
time um which was pretty awesome and i
got to go into the west wing and it was
very cool it's all very cool um but as i
was waiting there sidney powell was
actually checking into the hotel
and she follows me on twitter so i did
the the quick hello and obviously i
didn't want to waste too much of her
time and i had to run out anyway
but i basically said to her so listen
are you feeling good about
this thing do you do you feel like this
can happen
or you know is the cracking real bubba
she feels good about it now
i would assume she wouldn't tell me if
she didn't feel good about it but she's
still moving forward she strikes
me frankly as as a decent human being as
a patriot
that's trying to make something happen
here again
i'll just repeat myself into ad nauseam
i don't know
if what she is bringing to court
is true i don't you know she talked
about the drag and drop which they found
things
in the dominion software they could
literally drag you do this you know
like a cut and paste situation on your
computer where they could drag votes
from trump and drop them
to obama or they could drag him from
trump and drop them into the
the trash bin and the rest of it that's
just one of many allegations she's
making
she has a monumental herculean task to
do but she strikes me
she strikes me as a functional person in
no like she didn't have crazy eyes
she didn't seem bananas she seemed very
serious and everything else
uh and hopefully i can get her on the
show to talk about it she said she would
do it obviously she's a little busy at
the moment but if we can maybe do it on
the fly in a week or so
we'll try that uh lisa asks how was the
white house hanukkah party you know
it was absolutely wonderful everything
that this freaking country is about this
freaking
beautiful precious spectacular country
that we seem to be debating whether it
should continue or not
i felt like it was summed up at the
hanukkah party you know everybody
whatever your religion is
whether you're a jew or a christian or a
muslim or a hindu
or an atheist right a non-religious
person
everyone has been welcomed to the shores
of america to make a better life for
themselves right we all know this
this is the experience that all of us
have and in this country we don't have
laws that discriminate on those things
the idea
uh that people that have had a pretty
brutal history i mean it is my people
the jewish people
uh could have a party to celebrate um
to celebrate ironically i know this is
going to accept the leftists but the
story of hanukkah
is that a tiny bunch of jews in the
judean hills the judean you might know
what word that's connected to
jew judean in the west bank what now is
known as the west bank
uh that they defended their land and
their lives
uh from greek invaders right that's
that's the story of hanukkah it's
over 2000 years old uh now but we've got
people like ilhan omar and rashida talib
that'll say no jews are allowed to live
in the west bank i mean
that's a whole other a whole other story
but rashida talib
that buffoon i saw her today she tweeted
out like hanukkah wishes and it's like
lady
you literally don't want any jews to
live in the very land
that hanukkah celebrates i mean don't
take my word for it guys google the
story of hanukkah it's the
judean hills in jerusalem and what now
is known as the west bank so i guess
jews have been there for quite some time
anyway the party was great it was just
you know a lot of people knew me there
and
it was fun and you know some people wore
masks some people didn't wear masks i
had white house sushi which was pretty
good
uh they had lamb that was really great
uh the the staff was all wonderful and
it's just
cool i mean it's just to to be at the
white house
regardless of your political leanings
and everything else uh there were
actually two parties that day i was at
the earlier party
and trump did not come down for that one
i guess he's got a lot on his plate at
the moment but he did come down for the
later one and then i got to see video on
that
we tried to arrange a meeting with trump
and it didn't happen oh but actually
that's the next question right there
uh michael asks when can we expect an
interview with president trump
what is the first and most important
question so
we're working on it we've been in touch
with his people you guys know he's
mentioned me on fox and friends and he's
tweeted about me before
like we're we're well in the thing here
uh and we're gonna keep pushing it and
by the way i just
when i was in dc one of the things that
i did was i went to the blaze studios
over there which somehow i didn't even
know that they had studios and they've
got spectacular studios over there so i
may be spending a little more time
in dc and doing some shows out of there
and trying to get in a little bit more
in the political situation there but so
hopefully we can make the trump thing
happen
and what would be the first question you
know i think the first question
would be would be why
like why did you do it you know people
think oh he did it to make money
he did it to so he could build a road to
a golf course in
ireland with tax breaks and blah blah
blah like
why this country that has been so good
to you so good to your family you have
all of the things
that that anyone could want like all of
the material stuff and the fame
and all of that stuff like knowing how
awful the political system is how the
swamp works the way they destroy people
the lies all of that stuff like i guess
i would be
why did you do it like why put it all on
the line
and what is it within you that makes you
seem crazy enough to do it
and you know it's funny because
sometimes people ask something like me
they'll be like dave you seem
brave like you talk about this stuff
like what is it about you that does it
and and i suspect trump's answer would
probably be a little
i'm in no way comparing us but i think
his answer would probably be somewhat
similar which is
you just some people just there's
something in you and you just got to do
it i
can't even describe it any other way but
i hopefully would be able to get that
question to him
anya asks why do you think corporations
are supporting democrats who if
everything works the way they want will
impoverish
all of the consumers and as a result
corporations will make less money
if my logic is not there what are the
reasons
corporations support democrats so
there's a lot there but i would say
generally the democrats have become the
party of big
business who who is winning right now
and who is losing well the losing part
with lockdowns we know it's small
businesses small businesses are
absolutely decimated i think i read that
there's 31
000 restaurants either in los
angeles that that seems crazy or in the
socal area maybe the local socal area
maybe we could do a fact check on that
uh but 31 000 restaurants they're right
now virtually all closed if they can't
just become takeaway
restaurants right if they can't be 30
wow 30 000 restaurants
in los angeles that is that is
absolutely extraordinary these people
are hurting their lives are hurt and
everything else
now we know that big business and
lockdowns are hurting them so what is it
about democrats that in democrat-run
states
they are more than happy to shut down
all of these businesses destroy these
people's livelihoods but we allow best
spy to be open i picked up my nba jam
arcade machine
the other day you can get mba jam arcade
machine for 500 bucks 500 bucks i'm
playing it every
day and if you get on there if you get
it there's wi-fi and i'll play with you
guys if you want
using i'm using the 96 rockets right now
hakeem and clyde pretty great
um but why is it that that democrats
their policies seem to crush small
businesses lockdowns crush small
businesses but you can still go to
target you can still go to best buy
right
you can still go to big box stores we
know amazon's doing really well
and i think it has purely everything to
do
with money follow the money and see
where people are donating to
and don't for a second think that
democrat you know democrats what they're
really good at is saying we're for women
we're for black people we're for poor
people blah blah blah and they're not
for any of those things they're for
power
leftism is for power and that doesn't
mean that every democrat knows that and
i think there's a lot of willful idiots
and a lot of confused people and a lot
of people that don't take this stuff
very seriously and they oh you're for
poor people we're for you
like they don't think about it they
don't really think it through but in
essence
uh the republicans have become the party
of small business the engine of america
because they want to cut taxes cut
regulation take a chance man
go build a restaurant go go build a
business that you care about do
something innovate
do a start-up all of those things well
you can't do those in high tax places
which is why
all of these places are all of these
places of business are fleeing
california and our 82 degree sunny days
that we have every day they're fleeing
it to go to texas right now
ted asked did you see that disney went
all in on star wars and if so
what are you looking forward to so i did
see that they dropped like 10
series i guess there's gonna be a new
movie there's gonna be an offshoot of
clone wars
uh there's gonna be a prequel to rogue
one like a whole bunch of stuff
um you know i had a fairly hectic day
yesterday so i wasn't able to dive into
all of it but i'm
generally as a general rule with life
right now and i saw that there's a bunch
of new marvel stuff also
i'm kind of on board this like we need
new stories
thing you know what i mean like when in
1977 when star wars came out it was a
new story this
this sci-fi soap opera it was a new
story
about fathers and sons about good and
bad about
power and corruption and we've been
retelling these stories forever and i
think that the eternal
messages remain but i'm starting to
think we really need new characters and
maybe maybe those eternal messages
have to shift a little bit too maybe we
need or the messages i think have to
remain the same probably
to be true but you me you need new ways
of telling those stories maybe we'll get
some of that and as i said even though i
haven't been loving mandalorian i think
the last couple episodes have been good
and
you know getting ahsoka tanoo and is
great and all that stuff but
the idea that disney that just a giant
corporation
controls so much of what is thought of
as our our
creative stuff right like they
controlled
they control marvel they control star
wars they control the
the worlds of imagination a giant
corporation controls our worlds of
imagination
i'm pretty sure that would be in the
disney movie and they would be the bad
guys in the disney movie right like
isn't that
isn't that pretty much how it would work
like if this was the lego movie or
something like that so
i'm not like fully enthused but will i
try to watch them yeah i'll try to watch
them and give them all a go and
anyway i'd mostly fall asleep to these
things so it's fine um
kevin says what do you think is the best
way to reach out to children
to promote the concepts of freedom
rights hard work etc
uh well i don't have kids yet but we are
we are working on that and i hopefully
will have some
some updates on that front in the next
couple weeks if not
if not months but um i would say you
know
the best thing you can do is try to get
messages to kids
in in in memes and in
forms and in media that makes sense to
them
so you know i'll bring it back to star
wars for a second you know star wars is
not just the story of of
luke and darth vader but even if you
watch the prequels i always talk about
it for
from a libertarian perspective there's a
great story about power and absolute
power corrupting and what palpatine
was doing and starting a war to end a
war once he had accumulated enough power
like there's cool ways to get messages
across to young people and that's why we
need stories right
we need stories because not everything
can just be oh i got a book here and
it's a history book and this happened to
these people then and blah blah blah
you need stories to get those eternal
messages across
people can do it through biblical
stories that have stood the test of the
time
you can do it through creative stories
and again that's sort of why i would say
that one corporation controlling so much
of our
imagination is kind of is kind of
dangerous but i would say if they're a
little bit older than that
and you can't get them maybe to watch a
reuben report episode or
or you know a long form conversation
prageru videos
four-minute videos that are going to
teach you a little bit of something and
there's more and more of that out there
and by the way as long as the internet
remains relatively free and that could
all
end today i mean i could literally say
the wrong thing about the election and
they can pull the plug right now
but as long as we have a relatively free
internet i think there will always be
new people reinventing ways to to learn
and to teach and all of those things and
you just got to find it can you this is
candace can you possibly talk to one of
the candidates
for california governor on ruben reports
such as major williams
he seems great and i'd like to hear more
about his policies you know i'll tell
you something funny about just the
governor's situation here so first off
i'm 100
for recalling gavin newsom he's an
authoritarian lunatic who flaunts the
rules
in all of our faces and destroys
businesses while he as a millionaire
does whatever he wants
um but putting that aside uh you know
i've sort of like half jokingly said a
couple times and i guess i said it once
on fox and once on newsmax and it went
crazy
that i would run for governor against
this guy i have no desire i want to be
very clear i have no desire
to be a politician i like being a
functional member of society a
productive member of society why would i
ever want to be
a politician right like they're the
worst i don't want to control
people and this is the this is the crux
that liberty-minded people have
like progressives have a reason to be in
politics it's it's their religion
right it's their absolutely religion uh
it's their
it's their whole world view right they
view the world in a very horizontal way
it's only the stuff that's right here
they never look up
right they never look down they never
look up um
so i don't want to do that and i don't
think most liberty-minded people do
because they don't find their salvation
in politics
so what happens is you get a lot of bad
actors in politics
because they want to use the government
to accomplish a lot of stuff
and i don't want to do that so i think i
think what i'm doing now is
is the best use of my talents and skills
and passion which is that if i can get
some of these ideas across to you and
then you can spread them out in your own
life or whatever it is
then then that's the way to do it major
williams is a republican by the way
um and i would love to see some more
republicans running here we desperately
need it i mean
does anyone think california even if
you're the most progressive
lefty on the planet do you really think
california is being run well
we're going to cover this story more in
the next little while but there is a new
d.a
here in new district attorney here in
los angeles who was the district
attorney in san francisco
and he ruined san francisco and then of
course in progressive politics much like
gavin newsom you fell
up you ruined san francisco you fail up
you become governor this guy is now the
d.a here we had a black female
d.a here in los angeles but then bernie
supported this
white man gascon i don't care about
identify identity politics they do
he supported this guy he is now our d.a
and he just issued a new directive
they are not going to arrest people for
pr prostitution
they're not going to charge people
they're not going to charge people for
trespassing
resisting arrest in a series of other
things which means that literally
someone could hop the fence of my house
solicit prostitution on my front lawn
and then resist arrest for it and be
trespassing and i wouldn't be able to do
anything about it
do you see that we have a problem here
do you see i i sense major lawsuits
coming
uh let's see jonathan says do you like
the jim carrey grinch movie you know i
only saw it once
i did not love it but i have been to
universal studios here
in burbank in los angeles many times and
they have the entire
set the entire world there and that's
kind of cool it's kind of old and faded
at the moment but uh but that's kind of
cool seeing that stuff hopefully these
i love universal studio um in some ways
i like it more than even disney
disneyland um probably for some of the
reasons i described before about the
imagination stuff
uh but hopefully they'll reopen at some
point jenny says how do you show
civility to family members when they
disagree with you
and won't let the point go my mom is a
legacy media junkie and sometimes i get
the impression she thinks i'm insane for
being a moderate right-leaning person
man this is
this is probably the question of of the
day uh
not just for this but just like in
general i think everyone is dealing
with some version of this thing we're
watching families split apart we're
you know what the left has done over the
course of years and it's why i was
calling it out years ago
this idea of everyone that disagrees
with you is a nazi well you don't get to
be like a kind of minor oh he's just a
little bit of a nazi he's just a minor
junior nazi
it's like once they started using these
labels as their arguments
instead of making actual arguments they
were playing with fire
and i always said it was what they were
doing to themselves not what they were
doing to you because if you find out
that the nazi ain't that bad well then
you look like a real schmuck right you
can't
you know i guess i shouldn't have called
you a nazi even though i do see a lot of
public people that years ago were
calling me a racist and everything else
suddenly like
just repeating all the like a lot of
blue check well-known people just
repeating the things
now that i was saying years ago but it
doesn't give you room for it it doesn't
give you room to change and get better
and to be humble and have a little
humility
um but but on the family level i mean
this is really tough and to be
totally honest with you and i try to be
as honest with you guys as i can like
i'm dealing with versions of this in my
family at the moment
and i'm trying to deal with it the best
way i can and i always tell anyone that
by the way i'm never angry at anyone in
my family or my friends for their
political views
never never never never uh it seems to
only go one way
you guys know that like it's very rare
to hear the story
that someone says i'm i'm a conservative
and i have this
this view about this specific thing and
then my
cousin has this view or a friend that
has this view and i'm going to unfriend
them
or berate them and or everything else
usually what happens is people on the
right are willing to engage willing to
agree to disagree and the rest of it
it's people on the left and that again
was the danger because once you've
labeled them
nazis they're nazis they're deplorable
they're all of these things that are
that are just not
true you're basically saying they're not
human and they're evil and they're
sellouts and they're grifters that's why
all of these buzzwords
they're just meaningless right now and
and they really are the boy who cried
wolf
and when the real bad guys come which
they could
no one's gonna listen to these people
but i would say the best thing you can
do and this would be a lesson
for me just as much as it's a lesson for
you is
is try to turn the other cheek as much
as possible
but but don't be a patsy like don't
don't be bullied and the rest of it like
stand up for what you believe in i
constantly try to tell anyone that i'm
having these issues with family and
friends lifelong friends in some cases
like
i don't care i really mean that like i
don't care that we have a political
difference
i just view the role of government like
it really comes down to this
i simply view and i think most
right-leaning people we just
fundamentally view the role of
government
in a different way than left people do
people on the left seem to think the
role of government is to kind of manage
their lives and do everything and make
sure that everything is perfect and okay
and right leaning people are more wary
of power we go well no
let's let's try to make sure that that
isn't
exactly the way things are because we
know that power corrupts and we would
just prefer the government get out of
the way
and it's going to be a little messier
but you figure out how to
how to live your life on your own uh
felida says any chance you could get
christy gnome the south dakota governor
on reuben report
i believe we've tried a couple times and
we will keep trying i would love to
she's keeping her state open for the
most part she's out there
she's showing people you can go ahead
and live and i think she's obviously a
rising star on the republican side of
things so i'd be more than happy to do
that that would be great
um vic says what's the most rewarding or
interesting friendship sorry the most
interesting and or rewarding friendship
you've developed during this red pill
moment of your life um
i guess the two that'll that'll sort of
mean the most to you because they're
public i mean
you know first it was the jordan
situation that i got to tour
with the public intellectual of our time
bar none like there was nobody closer
and and if you don't believe that i mean
the proof was in the pudding we did
about 120 shows
in about 20 countries every single show
was sold out some showed out
sold out in minutes and we'd have to
repeat the show in the same city
um and and i got to see parts of the
country in parts of the world
and i got to know jordan in a way that
you know that i know that so many of you
would
would die to to get to know jordan that
way and you know to wake up
and a minute later you know we're we're
just hopping on a plane we're getting in
a bus
we're walking down the street and people
are coming up and telling them how we
changed our life and he helped me
fix my life um and i think i helped him
in certain ways too
you know and and we really became um
we became super close in that regard uh
you know obviously jordan's dealing with
some health stuff right now and he's he
has been
he has been coming back a little bit
more publicly and and a little bit more
and his book is coming out in march and
we're already talking about
uh doing an interview around that uh and
i hope to see him before that and i have
seen him in the midst of all of this
um but i but i'll take a different one
because jordan's been so
uh so off the grid so to speak for the
last little bit i would say glenn beck
probably
um you know if you would have asked me
years ago like what i thought of glenn
beck i i told glenn back
this once i i think the first time i had
him on my show you could see it in our
other studio
i said uh i said something like glenn
you know i thought you were half crazy
half
brilliant and and half an entertainer
and i know that's three halves but i
just thought that there was a lot there
um and it wasn't until i met him the
first time then subsequently over the
years i've been on his show many times
he's been on my show we've we've had
dinners in dallas and we've had dinners
in
los angeles and and i've spent a lot of
time with him and he's building this
incredible museum to
to to fight the terrible ideas
of the 1619 project and everything else
to reignite a pride in america
like i just i i view the world in such a
similar way
that he does and i'm so impressed with
that he's been able to build the blaze
build
these amazing digital properties and
things that are profitable and that work
and that are putting out something there
and he's just a good guy i mean
he's just a good guy really okay
stephanie says
what does faith look like to you today
positive or negative
um well i can say this without question
i i'm more of a believer
at this time in my life in 2020 at 44
years old than i
ever have been before for sure um
you know you know especially i think now
as we are
uh in the process of having kids and as
the world has gone so crazy i think you
do start thinking about your life more
seriously
um or at least i've started to think
about my life more seriously
and as i talk about in doper in this
book i think there's a functional reason
to believe
you know the way that the founders of
the united states said that you have
god-given rights there are things that
are beyond us as humans you're born
free the government can protect you
that's sort of a functional reason to
believe
um but i've come along to a to a
personal reason
to believe as well and um you know david
and i we
celebrate the jewish holidays it's
hanukkah right now it's night two
of eight crazy nights um so i'm sure the
adam sandler song will be played at some
point but we we light the candles
and we've been doing shabbat dinners
more i had dennis prager and his wife
over
and just for me it's about reconnecting
with tradition something that my
parents believed that my grandparents
believed and forefathers before that and
it's a
it's a long 5000 year history right it's
your
57 82 or something in the 57 37 what
year is it in the hebrew calendar get me
a number here we're fact checking on the
on the fly uh but i think having some
personal
belief outside of yourself i just think
is is deeply important and i think it's
why so many of
the people that are sort of the craziest
at the moment
i described this earlier a little bit
about why leftists are always looking
around the world like this thinking they
can manage everything
and they don't look up right they only
look horizontally they don't look
vertically
i think it's sort of why they're crazy
politics is a crazy game
and if your whole world is about
managing people and managing
managing politics like you will go crazy
it's 57-81
by the way want to be very clear about
that became 57-81 in september
of 2020. uh brandon says
do you feel we need to reexamine our
profit at all costs manifesto
and our perception of what success
really means um
well i would say that everyone has to do
that at a personal level
you know like you have to sort of blend
what you want in the world
meaning monetarily and and sort of
physically what are the things that you
want
big house fancy cars blah blah versus
what kind of life do you want to live do
you
do you want to burn it at both ends and
work relentlessly and
and and you know just put all of that in
so you can have stuff
or multiple houses or whatever it is or
can you figure out interesting ways to
do that like i don't think it's a
societal thing we can have those
conversations about what society she
wants
uh should want but i would basically say
that free market capitalism getting the
government out of the way so that you
can figure it out for yourself
and have a chance of success you know
just like roll the dice
and then hopefully put some hard work
and and have some good ideas and some
skill like that's that's pretty much the
way to do it
uh suggs mcgee says i know you're not
loving the mandalorian this season but
how are you feeling about the name
grugo do you think they'll eventually
name his uh species so as i said
i am enjoying it more now last two have
been good there's a new one on tonight
i don't mind the name grugo so grugo is
baby yoda
and i think we will find out more about
grugo the question is are all of the
yoda grugel
green creatures are they all force
enabled
we'll find out i suppose roz says thank
you for the most
aesthetically pleasing bookcase
background oh thank you very much
did you decorate it yourself if you used
a decorator perhaps you could give
scott adams the name these are my guys
so this was this was david and michael
and we had another lighting guy named
michael and uh and a few other people a
lot of the stuff
most of the stuff back there behind me
is from target by the way the the
um the globe right there is from target
obviously we got a couple books there
that's a that's a
that's a that's an emmy from john
stossel it's not it's a real emmy
and john stossel sent it to me one day
because i got his leftist wife
john stossel of course who's a huge
libertarian uh for decades in america
probably the most influential
libertarian for on in mainstream media
for many years
uh i got his wife to watch an interview
with thomas soule so he sent me a
an emmy which actually we took out of
the box and it was wrapped really crazy
and i actually broke it because you can
just see the bottom of it right there
and it's very very thin and i actually
broke it so we glued together john
stossel's emmy
then i've got a basketball that was used
in a trailblazers practice back in
around 91 or 92
and some of the greenery that's around
here it's all it's all uh it's all
target
but i will spread the word to scott
adams okay three more here we go real
quick
uh derek any chance we might see you run
for california political office
governor rubin has a nice ring to it
again i'm i'm trying to be a functional
member of society not a politician
um i i hope that some other good people
will be inspired enough to run against
these lunatics and these authoritarian
maniacs and i will gladly promote the
hell out of them please don't
put me in a position to have to run for
governor although i did watch
brewster's millions with richard pryor
and john candy last couple days and one
of the things he does you know he has 30
million dollars and if he spends it
within a month he gets 300 million
dollars
only a plot of the 80s um well he
decides to put sink a lot of the money
into a basically a campaign
for uh new york mayor against heller and
salvino and his
campaign slogan is none of the above
maybe i would do something like that
uh what would this hungry wolf what
would you make uh
once what would make you once and for
all leave california where would you go
you know i mentioned the thing about the
d.a before and they're not arresting
people for prostitution they're not
arresting people they won't be charging
people for
you know trespassing and we know that
homelessness is just crazy right now in
drug use and all of those things and
if la is to become san francisco and
maybe maybe that's a far gone conclusion
uh then we'll have to make some
decisions and you know we're thinking
about it and it sucks because
you know we've got a great house we've
got a great operation i have the stuff
that i want you know talking about the
material stuff i
genuinely don't want anything else you
know i wear the same five shirts
on this show and the same five jackets
and the same
h m underwear i've been wearing my whole
freaking life and like i don't want more
stuff and we've built something great
here and i do love
socal and the idea that you know you're
gonna have to leave certain states
depending on your beliefs it's like
that's a real condemnation of where
america is at and whether the
the union can continue the the
federalist experiment can continue so
i'm worried about that and i want to
stay and fight
as i've been telling you guys like i'm i
guess i'm a fighter i never thought of
myself as a fighter but
i want to stay and fight and fix this
like i don't want to just seed ground
just because these people are awful like
let's stay and fight and by the way i
meet more and more of you even just
walking my dog or
whatever going to the grocery store
looking like a criminal with a mask if
someone can occasionally recognize me
dave thanks you know that's what they
usually dave thanks that's what they say
and like they're like i'm here too
so there's more of us you know all right
one more if biden and harris are the
person of the year who would you
be who would be the loser or worst
person of the year
also who should actually be the person
of the year that seems like the right
question to end on
so joe biden and kamala harris are times
person of the year
now a lot of people are saying but wait
a minute that's two people it shouldn't
be person and we can make all the jokes
about
uh pronouns and all that um but i would
say that actually they are one person
because joe biden is the vessel
right he is the vessel and she is the
parasite which will burst forth
from his stomach she's just feeding off
his old body
using his nutrients to gestate in the
stomach and then she will burst
forth and take over via the 25th
amendment so technically i think you can
say that they are one creature
at the moment uh for more on that check
out alien obviously the alien movies a
lot of a lot of bursting forth of things
and you'll have a better understanding
of the gestation process
of the alien the parasite related to the
host and everything else
um of course they shouldn't have been
times personnel none of it matters no
one gives a [ __ ] about time magazine
anymore like it's a joke
it's like everything else in mainstream
media it's just a joke of itself
um they've accomplished nothing but
let's not forget you know barack obama
won the nobel prize for doing absolutely
nothing
um who who should have been the person
of the year
i mean i think the answer that i'm
getting on twitter a lot on this one or
that i'm seeing people tweet about
is it should be the first responders you
know because sometimes they'll just do
like a group he'll put up a picture of
one person
and it could be the first responders i
think that would be fine but
i would say dare i say it i hey i've
gone this far it should be donald trump
it should be donald trump the world was
defined
by donald trump either the love you have
for him or the hate you have for him and
there's very little in between
but i would say as we sit here
uh you know in the second week of
december 2020 you know five weeks away
from potentially
biden coming in or potentially a second
trump administration happening
it's like the world still revolves
around that and everything we're seeing
right now with the election fights and
with censorship
and virtually everything and lockdowns
virtually
everything that is that is in our
national zeitgeist still revolves around
donald trump
so joe biden is just an old guy who
never did anything
worthwhile for 47 years in government
and kamala harris is just the parasite
who's
again gestating in the host so there you
go on that one
i'll try to jump in the uh the community
at reubenreport.com and you can also
download the reuben report app or the
locals app and i'll try to
over the weekend uh you know communicate
with you guys a little bit more answer
some of the questions
that i did not get to uh and finally
guys we're back to the normal schedule
next week so we're live monday through
friday at 11 a.m
uh pacific and the numbers have just
been great and i'm i'm reading all as
many of the emails as i can and i thank
you guys for the support
uh oh and by the way next week's sit
down will be abba
abigail schreier the off author hang on
it's a lot of talking you know uh next
week's sit down will be
with abigail schreier author of
irreversible damage
the book is currently sold out
everywhere you may have heard a few
weeks ago
target banned the book because she talks
about young girls transitioning
and the trans movement in general and
what's happening with so many young
people
and the book was banned because one
person on twitter didn't like it then
there was an uproar the book got put
back
it's sold out everywhere i did the
interview with her already but we wanted
to hold it a little bit because we're
waiting for the book to get restocked
and it should be in the next couple days
uh that's it and again next tuesday 5
p.m pacific we're going to do our
v for vendetta movie night at the reuben
report community so i hope you guys will
join us
have a great weekend i will not be on
the twitter or on any of the machines
except as i said maybe in the community
have a great weekend everybody stay sane
goodbye
you